hello everyone my name
is bradley today i'd like to talk to you
about all the incriminating evidence
that hackers
and other cyber criminals leave behind
so look what do you imagine when you
hear the words hacker or cybercriminal
do you envision some kind of reclusive
genius who hasn't gotten up from his
keyboard in maybe 20 years
perhaps you imagine someone who can get
their hands on anything in the digital
world
or perhaps someone that can read any
message break into any device or
steal money from any bank in the world
well
that's the image that's often given off
by hollywood films and sensational news
articles
what's left out of the picture is how
hackers ultimately get caught by law
enforcement
[Music]
and that's exactly what i want to dig
into today
so back in 2012 wormer was a well-known
figure
among both hackers as well as the
conventional i.t community
the anonymous affiliated hacker managed
to break into several government
computer systems
notably he broke into the new york
police department's computer system
now a year prior to this the nypd had
violently cracked down on occupy wall
street protesters now many of those
officers used violent tactics such as
using batons and pepper spray
and many had even covered their badges
so as to conceal their real identities
now thanks to wurma the identities of
those very officers were made public and
obviously many applauded
werma for this act but others were
really outraged wemma definitely took a
liking to all of this attention he was
getting
just like zorro he would leave traces of
himself at the scene of a hack
including a word that was instantly
recognizable to anyone who had surfed
the web 10 years ago
pawned but burma also had a habit of
leaving funny pictures behind
and one of those pictures ultimately led
to his downfall this
is the very picture i'm talking about
now is there anything here that you
think would give him away
well to answer this question you don't
actually need to look at the actual
picture
but rather the file itself starting in
the early 2000s
digital images began to contain what's
called exif data
now in short an exif is a type of text
that contains the main parameters of any
given photograph
which can include the make and the model
of the camera the shutter speed the iso
and so on but this information alone
would really not have been enough to
catch wormer
except for one important detail photo
was taken by wurma's fiancee
specifically on her brand new iphone and
unlike a regular camera an iphone has a
gps chip
which recorded the exact location at
which this photo was taken
nowadays many of us know that our
iphones constantly track where we are
but back in 2012 this was still
relatively new technology
so the police were actually able to use
this picture's exit data to pinpoint a
small house in the suburbs of melbourne
australia and there they found a woman
who quickly admitted that her boyfriend
had actually asked her to take the
picture and to no surprise this
boyfriend turned out to be wermer
himself now soon enough the police were
able to figure out where his true
identity he was a 30 year old software
engineer living in texas by the name of
figenio akoa
and they also got hold of his social
media accounts too including his
facebook messages
his at ananwama twitter handle and
in all these there was plenty of
incriminating evidence
woman was pretty quick to admit his
guilt and he was eventually found guilty
and imprisoned
although he was released in 2015 from
prison we're actually had to deal with a
less common form of punishment
which is actually being banned from the
internet
so if he wants to for instance watch a
netflix documentary about himself
well he'd have to ask his wife to do the
clicking for him
nowadays many websites use exif data
facebook use it to make maps of all your
travels
google readily admits that images with
exif data are prioritized by a search
engine
because of this whenever you upload
images of yourself online
be aware that hackers can actually use
the exif data within your photograph to
track you down
so look how do we fight back against
this
well for starters you can actually
prohibit your phone camera from
accessing your location data
this is one of the more simple solutions
but be aware that if you do happen to
update your device your camera
could go back to default and collect
your location data so
while i thoroughly recommend this method
it may not guarantee
full anonymity all of the time my next
recommendation is to manually check the
exif data of all of the photos you
upload
you may wish to change or delete
whatever data within the photo you're
not comfortable with sharing
now for this you'd actually need to
install specific software on your
computer
you might need to download an app on
your phone or even use a service that
specializes in just this on the other
hand there are some benefits to exif
data which you might not have considered
for instance you could locate a stolen
phone or a camera this way just by
looking at the photos
and there are actually services that can
help you with that by scouring the net
for photos that are taken with the
stolen device
now if you want to find out how much
information is stored in just one
photograph
you can do this yourself just simply
upload a file onto the exifer.net and
click
exit me
i'd now like to welcome to the stage a
man by the name of jeremy hammond
he's the founder of hackthissite.org and
he's well known for a pretty
schoolboy era he made back in 2012. now
jeremy hacked into the private
intelligence firm stratfor
as a result thousands of military
documents were leaked onto the internet
detailing a wide range of different
sensitive government secrets now you'd
think that jeremy being an experienced
hacker wouldn't leave much of a trace
right
well while the fbi was able to track him
down they weren't able to gather much
from his computer because his hard drive
was so well encrypted
plus you'd probably expect that hammond
wasn't very keen on showing his password
which you can imagine would have been
tens of digits long right
so very well could have been that
hammond got away scot-free
if it hadn't been for one small detail
jeremy
really liked his cat so much so that his
password
was in fact the name of his cat and just
to make that password
much more difficult to crack he threw in
a few numbers
at the end well one two three so
the password used by a man who hacked
confidential government secrets was um
chewy123
now unsurprisingly this wasn't too
difficult for investigators to figure
out
and needless to say the technical
experts at the fbi couldn't believe how
easy it was to guess
to achieve this you need some top of the
line equipment now when it comes to
password guessing some of you may have
heard of the brute force method
which involves guessing every possible
combination of letters and numbers
now this of course is no easy task so if
someone wants to guess your password
they'll have to try a combination of
commonly used passwords first and
well if that doesn't work then they'll
answer information about you
including what you do what you like who
you know and so on
then maybe adding a few common numbers
at the end and using these keywords
someone can try and guess your password
so if you're a huge football fan
i wouldn't recommend using the password
ronaldo one
but this method actually landed one of
the most infamous hackers
in the world in prison i want to pay my
respects to the comrades lockdown doing
hard time but staying strong
and show my appreciation for the abcs
the bookstore prisoners the certain days
calendar
those who wrote letters those who
visited those who attended court dates
i appreciate you unfortunately millions
of us use similarly
weak passwords so please do check if any
of your passwords are the names of your
relatives or pets or
maybe even your favorite sports team and
so on if so
then you're on very thin ice
but even the best be it a long or
randomized password doesn't necessarily
guarantee
full security the creator of the largest
drug selling website
learned this from his own experience
ross william albrecht
known as the dead pirate roberts was
very cautious when it came to security
and of course the password on his
computer well
that he used to control the silk road
was so strong
that it was almost impossible to guess
now
fbi agents in charge of this arrest
understood this perfectly well
therefore they developed a dramatic
takedown operation
they actually staged a fight between
visitors in the public library of san
francisco
warbricht was working on his website
ulbrich turned away from his laptop to
see what was happening understandably so
and as soon as he did
another agent grabbed the open computer
now almost at once all of the secrets
of the main darknet based drug lord
literally ended up in the hands of the
fbi
i hope you don't do any shady business
but i still wouldn't recommend
leaving your computer unattended open in
a public library
i mean in the end logging out of your
account just takes a couple of taps on
your keyboard right
i hope that i was able to illustrate how
simple mistakes can have enormous
consequences for your online safety so
make sure that you pay attention to how
you keep your data safe whether it's
the passwords that you're putting into
certain sites or even
the metadata included in certain images
because as you've seen even the most
clever
of hackers have made tiny errors that
have turned their lives completely
upside down you're watching some sub my
name is bradley and as always it's been
a pleasure
also don't be like jeremy hammond don't
use your cat's name as a password with
one two three stuck on the end use
something original
anyway i'll see you in the next video
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]
you